I wrote it, I sent it, I'm ****d
- I think it's important
to first address
that I'm sort of a piece
of (bleep) on Twitter.
Because mostly
what I do on there
is just pick out
people I don't like
and then just badger
them and harass them
until they're either
forced to respond to me
or do the smart thing
and completely ignore me.
Like in the past, I got in
an argument with Tom Hanks's
rapping son Chet Hayes and
also the food franchise
Soup Plantation because
that name is racist, period.
But the one that's
most important to me
is garbage person Chris Brown.
On May 5th, I tweeted,
it's Cinqo de Mayo,
so when you're
beating up a pinata,
keep in mind it's also
Chris Brown's birthday.
Chris Brown once tweeted,
do you know Chris Brown?
Which is a question I
still don't understand
but I retweeted it and put,
is what detectives ask
all your girlfriends.
And sometimes I get
political, like I tweeted,
Mike Pence running
with Donald Trump
is like the time Chris Brown
did a song with Pitbull.
So again, I just send these
out mindlessly, I'm an idiot,
and then I looked
down at my phone,
and it said, Chris Brown
is now following you.
Which is normally
something that would make
a woman run to a police station,
and then a minute later, I
got another email that said,
you have a direct
message from Chris Brown.
So I open it up, and it just
says plainly in two words,
(bleep) you.
Makes sense, but Chris Brown
was smarter than I was.
He went back into my
Twitter and liked over 200
of my tweets, which I kinda
thought was nice or cute
but then I realized, Chris
Brown fans are so maniacal
and fanatic that they look
at everything he likes.
So immediately, they were
like, why would Chris Brown
like 200 tweets from
a guy who looks like
the Verizon spokesperson?
And the answer was, because
then they can harass me back.
So for almost two years,
I would get tweets
that say, (bleep) you, team
breezy, over and over again.
And you know what,
I deserved it.
Pro-tip, Chris Brown doesn't
only fight with his fists,
he also uses his
Twitter fingers.